you remember the gay frogs that's that  is  100 my favorite conspiracy theory that  turned out to be true when Alex Jones  said on air they're turning the freaking  frogs gay  and then everybody made fun of him  and then he was totally right  whatever Alex Jones has ever said in his  life it is simply a fact  they were turning the freaking frogs gay  there was a team of scientists from Yale  that analyzed 21 ponds in Suburban  Connecticut  and found actually not only were they  turning the frogs gay they were turning  them trans  genic waste in the in the water in these  ponds was turning the frogs  hermaphroditic So Not only was Alex  Jones's crazy conspiracy theory true it  actually didn't go far enough he was  actually too modest in his commentary